[Music]
the reason that Robert Muller spoke
publicly this week is because he was
more worried about his legacy than he
wasn't protecting this country this is
counter to everything he was taught and
supposedly stood for and is not only
disappointing but politically damaging
Malu was charged with serving the United
States of America and not his ego yet
that is exactly how he will now be
remembered Muller had a case of sellers
remorse when the seller regrets what
he's already sold it seems Bob is
afflicted with a serious case of this
remorse the original report didn't hurt
Trump enough ask yourselves one question
why after ten weeks after the special
council report is submitted
does Muller unilaterally decide to hold
a press conference to say he's closing
shop and why does Muller do a Jim Comey
and say I didn't charge but only because
dot dot dot why he does it to rally the
left because the Muller report didn't
hurt enough mind you the report is the
best evidence of the investigation it is
the investigation there's no need to
unilaterally emphasize or add to the
document not robert muller he decides to
jump into the political fray just like
his pal Jim Comey did and now the calls
for impeachment are echoing throughout
Congress this was not the case when the
report was submitted so Muller I imagine
at the behest of the left gives them
what they need to jumpstart the calls
for impeachment but nothing has changed
in the report the only thing that has
changed is Muller deciding to create
chaos and havoc as if two years of an
investigation of the president showing
absolutely
no-trump Russia collusion and no
obstruction are not enough but that's
exactly what Muller did muddy up the
waters and charged up the left after
that investigation if we had had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so now they never said that in the
report
so now Muller is adding look I'm not
confident you didn't commit a crime
folks that is sheer lunacy I don't know
a prosecutor in this country who has
ever said after a grand jury
investigation I'm not sure he didn't
commit a crime
you either indict or you don't you don't
come out and say you know that Vinnie
boombots
I'm not dating him but man I'm telling
you he ain't a good guy every prosecutor
knows if you don't indict someone you
stop there so what was the point of the
400-plus report the report doesn't say
I'm not confident you didn't commit a
crime
so then what's the endgame now let's
take a second to talk about collusion
not the Trump Russia collusion but what
about collusion between Muller and the
Democrats the Democrats don't have an
independent thought other than their
hatred of Donald Trump
the Muller report didn't accomplish
their goal the Democrats are desperate
they need Muller to shake things up so
they can rally the troops around
impeachment think about it what are the
Democrats offer other than all things
anti Trump you did not however make a
determination as to whether the
President did commit a crime and why the
heck not what did you and your gang of
Trump hating Hillary loving lawyers do
for two years he uses as an excuse that
he couldn't indict because the Office of
Legal Counsel guidelines says you cannot
indict a sitting prayer
yet even unflappable Attorney General
Bill Barr took offense to that one
special counsel Muller stated three
times to us in that meeting in response
to our questioning that he emphatically
was not saying that but for the OLC
opinion he would have found obstruction
we did not understand exactly why the
special counsel was not reaching a
decision and when we pressed him on and
he said that his team was still
formulating the explanation still
formulating an explanation as to why it
didn't reach a decision on obstruction
are you stupid
you had two years to think about that
one and he did not instead he punted and
now Muller wants to come out and say
look we never said he didn't we simply
couldn't make a decision because he's a
sitting president folks that's baloney
what was the point of this investigation
in the first place what did you do for
two years Bob you could have reached a
conclusion without charging by simply
stating your conclusion or your opinion
and by the way when did you know there
was no collusion did you know that
before the midterms you could have shut
the whole thing down but then again it
was a major help to the Democrats now
wasn't it and you're helping them yet
again so let's recap neither the
president nor anyone on the Trump
campaign colluded with Russia you
couldn't make a decision on obstruction
and by law the Attorney General and
Deputy Attorney General had to do so so
who the hell asked you this week to come
out muddy the waters like Jim Comey did
in 2016 I guess we now have a
competition between holier-than-thou Jim
Comey and mixed up Monsignor Muller both
members of the choir of nevertrump errs
in the Church of the demon rats because
that's what this is all about nothing
more and nothing less and that's my open
let me know what you think on my
Facebook and Twitter hash tag judge
Jeanine